hey guys as a well expected for a long
time at an end of the final season of
Game of Thrones HBO Villines some kind
of spin-off prequel or sequel series a
new series based on George RR Martin's
fictional universe a few days ago it's
been revealed that a Jew is in the
process of developing four ideas from
multifarious writers to keep George RR
Martin's fictional world on our screens
for a long time while HBase surprisingly
developing for potential Game of Thrones
spinoff series that will explore
different time periods in an expansive
George our merchants world that doesn't
mean that HBO will release for Game of
Thrones spinoff series
additionally in my opinion among those
four ideas from four different writers
only one you'll actually go into
production before we consider a few
possibilities about what Game of Thrones
spin-off series might be about let me
just say that among those four projects
that are under consideration
George is being personally attached only
to two of them David Benioff and Dan
Weiss co-creators and showrunners of
Game of Thrones even though they
previously said that they do not plan to
be involved in envelope projects
actually will be attached to all four
potential projects as executive
producers but will not contribute as
writers with all of this being said and
with margin statement that there are
eight million stores sinestro's and even
more in Essos and glens beyond a whole
world full of stories waiting to be told
let's see what might be the story that
HBO will decide to introduce us with in
the upcoming game of journal spin-offs
while the possibilities for the spin
uploader and less Robert's rebellion is
doubts among those stories that we are
as Martin said waiting to be told
Robert's rebellion also known as the War
of the usurper was a rebellion against
House Targaryen primarily instigated by
Eddard Stark Jon Arryn and Robert
Baratheon the war was sparked and Prince
Rhaegar Targaryen kidnapped Lee Ann
stark which eventually resulted with the
death of the Ennis father and brother
upon protesting this act of the Mad King
the rebellion officially began when King
Aerys called for the heads of Leanna's
betrothed Robert Baratheon and her
second brother Eddard Stark who were
under the care of warden of the East Jon
Arryn instead of turning a turd and
Robert over to King's justice
Lord John rates his banners in rebellion
against these unjust acts and sent
Robert broth
Eddard Stark back to their lands to
rally their man Robert's rebellion
lasted almost a year and resulted with
the end of Targaryen dynasty in the
Seven Kingdoms
not only that Robert's rebellion would
provide a simmers battles along with the
famous Battle of the Trident during
which Robert killed Rhaegar in single
combat at a blow to the chest from kids
Warhammer but would also reveal the full
truth behind the relationship between
Lyanna stark and Prince Rhaegar that led
to John's birth a big amount of us would
like to see Robert's rebellion in the
potential spin-off george RR martin
doesn't agree a year ago while being
contacted by Entertainment Weekly Martin
reveal what his thoughts are about
potential spin-off martin said the most
natural follow-up would be an adaptation
of find and connect stories each of the
novellas could easily be done as to our
standalone movie for television that
would probably be the ideal way to do
them rather than as an ongoing weekly
series the hedge Knight and its sequels
are lighter than a Song of Ice and Fire
more in the realm of action-adventure in
case you don't know the dunk and egg
stories are ongoing series of novellas
set in the world of Song of Ice and Fire
pretty close to the main novels three
novellas have appeared so far with six
to twelve stories being planned in a
series the stories relate the adventure
so the hedge nights are Duncan the tall
who would become legendary member of the
Kingsguard and his squire egg who will
become King Aegon v Targaryen the
stories begin with their meeting eighty
nine years before the events of the main
novels the only issue is Duncan X
stories his lack of source material to
work with as Martin said himself
each of those three novellas could be
done into two hours worth of screen time
but on the other hand there are six to
twelve stories being planned in a series
considering George RR Martin's statement
about potential spinoff
along with the fact that he is being
personally attached to two out of four
potential Game of Thrones spin-off
series that HBO is developing the dunk
and egg stories being a new story that
we are going to be introduced it most
certainly is not out of the realm of
possibilities let me just highlight that
the set date for this spinoff is unknown
as HBO said there is no set timetable
for this project along with the
statement will take as much or as little
time as the writers need
need and as with all our development we
will evaluate what we have in the
scripts RN meaning that there will most
probably be a gap between the end of
Game of Thrones and the new George RR
Martin's fictional universe related
series and as always let me know your
opinion about all of this in the comment
section down below I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next piece
[Music]